the first time you actually met Ben
Affleck well I met him years ago a
telethon and I had to explain to him who
everybody was that was like under 30
he was just sitting next to me so he was
like hey like who are these I was like
well the Jonas Brothers are and it's my
best time since I had that you know like
in the in the bank like he he was cool
to me like from the get-go cuz he's like
oh yeah you're that girl's okay I'm sure
he's daughters short pitch perfect man
I haven't asked about that but I think
he I think he is like a not so
undercover puts perfect man thank you
right you are not too picky I'm shabby
when it comes to your male co-stars a
shared George Clooney I mean then you
got Timberlake a flow who was like the
coolest down-to-earth she's got the
problem they're all so great i mean i
gorge obviously and ryan reynolds was
what was a guy where i was like how are
you this normal like just so funny and
cool tymberlee yeah i mean what's he
like on set is he singing all the time
he normally doesn't but the other day we
were in London and I think both of us
were really jet-lagged and he was
singing without noticing it which was
like doubly annoying because like you're
singing and then you're so good and I
was like what was that worth you just
pulled out of nowhere at 6:00 in the
morning and he was like oh was i singing
like genuine genuinely like I didn't
write it like whatever I know I hate him
you